[Musique]
nous allons un problème institutionnel
monsieur le premier ministre c'est cela
dont nous voulons vous parler
aujourd'hui les mesures sanitaires vont
dans le bon sens mais on prend des
mesures qui touchent aux libertés
publiques
quand on touche à la liberté d'aller et
venir quand on touche à la liberté du
commerce
quand on empêche les gens d'aller et
venir d'une région à l'autre d'un
département à l'autre
c'est sûrement très nécessaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces mesures nous
les a mais simplement il s'agit de
libertés publiques sera au delà du
réglementaire ça va au delà de
l'administration et il n'est pas anormal
que le parlement puisse apprécier la
proportionnalité des mesures qui ont été
prises
[Musique]
pourtant
pour
l'âge a de quoi surprendre côte à côte
en conférence de presse droite centre
gauche et écolo tous ont écouté le vote
qui suivait la déclaration de jean
castex les tribunes ils sont plusieurs
comme le sénateur centriste pays hervé
marseille à s'en prendre au processus de
décision
vous avez parlé ce matin vous avez dit
la démocratie c'est la transparence
est ce que vous croyez franchement que
le conseil de défense est un exemple de
transparence
au delà de nos différences assez
inhabituel effectivement que nous
exprimions collectivement et en le
marquant par un vote qui constitue une
alerte démocrate continue comme ça il ya
des institutions et l'action d'un seul
homme fût-il le président de la
république peut pas constituer l'alpha
et l'oméga de la politique française
il faut faire vivre des institutions les
institutions elle prévoit que c'est le
gouvernement qui doit gouverner qui est
responsable devant le parlement
[Musique]